any Christian who spends more than 5
Seconds talking to Muslims online will
be asked how can you believe that one +
1 + 1 equals 1 Muslims are so incredibly
proud of this objection that they post
it over and over and over again 1 + 1 +
1 equal 1 right 1 + 1 + 1 equal 1
Christians answer Christianity God is
one 1 + 1 + 1 = 1 Islam 1 equal 1 y'all
should take a hit at the Islamic Bel of
one God if you do I know it would just
be a bunch of Lies saying no one is not
equal to 1 Christian in school taking a
test 1 + 1 + 1 equal 3 Pass Christian in
church for 2,000 years before God 1 + 1
+ 1 equal 1 fail double standard but you
believe 1 + 1 + 1 equal 1 speak now
don't post a comment then make it funny
you lying when you say 1 + 1 + 1 equal 1
that means either you're lying or you're
illiterate which one is it 1 + 1 + 1
equal 1 in Trinity I think you say 1 + 1
+ 1 equal 1 that's the problem Islam is
very simple one Allah and many prophets
Christian 1 + 1 + 1al
1 mathematical mockery 1 + 1 + 1al 1 is
by far the most common Muslim objection
to the doctrine of the Trinity now when
Muslims post this objection Christians
often respond with some basic
mathematics they point out that 1 * 1 *
1 equals 1 or if the Muslim demands that
we use addition when we're talking about
God Christians will point out that the
god of the Bible unlike the god of the
Quran is infinite so it would be more
accurate to say infinity plus infinity
plus infinity equals
infinity I'd like to help our Muslim
friends with their math skills by
stressing something even more
basic when we learn math in school we
learn to use numbers in an abstract
manner 2 + 2 = 4 2 + 2 what well it
doesn't matter we're using the numbers
by themselves without referring to
specific objects but if you're adding up
things in the real world you need to
include units inches pounds jelly beans
whatever and the units need to be the
same on both sides of the equal sign
if you're adding up blocks then two
blocks plus two blocks equal four blocks
if you take a th blocks and use them to
build one house you wouldn't say that 1
+ 1 + 1 all the way up to a th equals 1
even though the Thousand blocks do make
one house if you made one house out of a
thousand blocks and someone said LOL
this guy thinks that a th000 equals 1
you'd probably want to explain how units
work in math if the units you're adding
are blocks you can't change the units to
house in the answer and then take out
all the units and pretend that a th000
equals 1 if you do you'll end up with a
mathematical
absurdity consider a few simple examples
of what happens when you don't clarify
which units you're using how old was
Aisha when Muhammad consummated the
marriage with her she was 9 years old
but wait a minute how could Aisha be
nine if there was only one of her are
Muslims telling us that 9 equal 1 are
they telling us that 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 + 1 + 1 + 1 equals 1 is this how math
Works in Islam this would be a silly
objection wouldn't it why because when
we talk about one Aisha we're talking
about one being one little girl but when
we're talking about her age nine we're
talking about something completely
different if you conveniently leave out
the fact that we're talking about very
different features of Aisha her nature
versus her age you end up with
mathematical
absurdities here here's another proof
that according to Islam 9 equals 1 sah
bukari
5068 narrated onus the prophet used to
go around have sexual relations with all
his wives in one night and he had nine
wives so each of Muhammad's nine wives
could say that she had sex with Muhammad
during one of these sexathon and yet sex
with nine different wives somehow added
up to one night of sex for the prophet
of Islam so according to Islam 1 + 1+ 1
+ 1+ 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 equals 1 but it
gets worse sahil bukari
268 narrated katata anas bin Malik said
the prophet used to visit all his wives
and around during the day and night and
they were 11 in number 11 in number I
thought thought it was N9 so now 11
equal 9 and 9 equals 1 I'm confused I
asked onest had the prophet the strength
for it meaning did Muhammad have the
sexual strength to handle 11 women and
girls in a single night anest replied we
used to say that the prophet was given
the strength of 30 men and sah said on
the authority of katada that anas had
told him about nine wives only not 11 so
Muhammad had the sexual strength of 30
men this means that we can add up the
sexual strength of one man and the
sexual strength of another man and the
sexual strength of another man until we
get the sexual strength of 30 men and it
will equal the sexual strength of one
Prophet Muhammad so 1+ 1+ 1+ 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 + 1 + 1 + 1 equals one in Islam right
now these are just some goofy examples
to illustrate the utter Ridiculousness
of claiming that when someone says that
something is one in one way but more
than one in another way he's actually
saying that 3 or 9 or 11 or 30 equals 1
mathematically here Fe our Muslim
friends May reply but David we're not
talking about Aisha we're not talking
about Muhammad's sex life we're talking
about
God funny I thought we were talking
about math but I hear you let's talk
about your
God according to Islam Allah has literal
body parts lots of Muslims don't know
this but their Scholars do their
Scholars will admit that Allah has a
literal Shin a face a foot or two feet
depending on whom you ask two right
hands and so on so Allah described in
the Quran that he has a face Allah
mentioned that we made Adam by our hands
Allah described in the Quran that he has
two hands the Hadith says very clearly
that both his hands are right we believe
that both of the hands of Allah are what
huh both of them are right how I don't
know
the here refers to Allah's Shin so he
has a leg number 68y number 42 the shin
of Allah is mentioned Allah says inah Al
that on the day of judgment Allah would
uplift and show his leg if you read the
fingers of Allah are mentioned the
prophet tells us that the prophet has
that Allah has fingers the Quran says
that Allah has one eye and another Ayah
says he has multiple eyes Allah tells us
about himself subhanahu wa'ta'ala that
he has an eye so all these are a direct
indication that Allah has got a shape
they'll just qualify this by saying that
we can't comprehend Allah's Shin face
foot or feet right hands and so on
because nothing is like
Allah so how many incomprehensible but
literal body parts does Allah have let's
say it's 10 you see where I'm going with
this don't
you Allah is one in one way but more
than one in another way he's one on the
level of being but more than one on the
level of body parts following the method
that Muslims use then we would say that
Allah's body parts add up to one Allah
which means that if Allah has 10 body
parts 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1
+ 1 is equals one but Allah gets even
more confusing because Allah is more
than one not just in body parts but in
other kinds of attributes Allah has 99
names so he's one in nature but 99 in
name which means that 99 equals 1 in
Islam Allah's 99 Names correspond to 99
attributes and Allah's attributes can be
in conflict with one another as we read
in Sun IB maah
4295 it was narrated from Abu hura that
the messenger of Allah said when Allah
created the universe he decreed for
himself my Mercy prevails over my
wrath Allah's attribute of Mercy is in
conflict with his attribute of Wrath but
his Mercy triumphs over his wrath this
means that Allah's Mercy is not the same
thing as his Wrath there are
distinctions within the nature of Allah
so Allah is one in one way essence or
being or nature but he's more than one
in another way he's more than one in
attribute but when Christians say that
God is one in one way essence or being
or nature but more than one in another
way more than one in person our Muslim
friends tell us that we're bad at math
well if we're bad at math then Muhammad
was really really bad at math now we
talked about Allah what about the
Quran how many suras are there in the
Quran that depends on which Quran we go
to Muhammad's companion Abdullah IB
masud only had 111 suras in his Quran
Muhammad's companion ubai bin KB had 116
suras in his Quran the Quran that
Muslims use today is descended from the
one that was put together by by Zade IB
Tabit and the Zade IB Tabit Edition had
114 suras but there's only one Quran
right so 111 = 114 equal 116 in Islam
that's weird but let's just stick with
the Zade IB Tabit Edition there are 114
suras in zad's Quran 114 suras one Quran
so 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1
+ 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1
+ 1+ 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 + 1+ 1+ 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1
+ 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1+ 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 + 1+ 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1+ 1 + 1 + 1
+ 1 + 1 equals 1 according to Islam
things get more interesting when we
think about the nature of those suras
what is a Surah of the
Quran what is Surah 2 for instance what
is its
nature you Muslims will say that its
nature is the Quran or that it's the
speech of Allah so different suras of
the Quran share that same nature don't
they they all share the same nature as
the Eternal speech of Allah don't they
okay let's think about this
is Surah 1 identical to Surah 2 is Surah
2 identical to Surah 3 Surah 1 is
distinct from Surah 2 isn't it Surah 2
is distinct from Surah 3 isn't it and
yet their nature what they are is the
same because they're all the Quran or
the speech of Allah so Surah one is the
Quran Surah 2 is the Quran Surah 3 is
the Quran but Surah 1 is not Surah 2
Surah 2 is not Surah 3 Surah 3 is not
Sur one you Christians who are watching
May recognize this as an illustration of
the concept of the Trinity the father is
God the son is God the holy spirit is
God but the father is not the son the
son is not the Holy Spirit the holy
spirit is not the father our Muslim
friends tell us that this is impossible
and and yet we can use the same
illustration for the Quran the only
difference is that if we wanted to be
accurate we'd need a figure with 114
sides and there's no way I'm drawing
that way too
complicated now if each of the 114 suras
is the Quran are there 114 qurans I
thought there was only one
kurran it seems that Muslims believe
that the Quran is one in essence or
nature but 114 in Surah or chapter the
Quran is one in one way but more than
one in another way but with all the
Muslim mockery of the Trinity I thought
it was impossible to be one in one way
but more than one in another
way what about the seven aru according
to Muhammad the Quran was revealed in
seven aru seven different modes or forms
Muslims today claim that this simply
refers to different dialects but there's
no way this is just different dialects
because people who spoke the same
dialect were reciting different
aru what are the different
aru sad story no one knows but whatever
the seven different modes or forms are
there's only one Quran right so the
Quran is one in essence or being or
nature but seven in mode or form what
about the 10 official Kat the 10
different recitations or readings of the
Quran the different kirat contain
different Arabic letters and different
Arabic words and this led to differences
in the text of the Quran in different
parts of the world and today most
Muslims read the Quran in a text that is
referred to as the Egyptian Edition uh
of 1924 to Muslims in general this is
just simply the Quran uh but this is not
the only text of the Quran that is read
throughout the world in other words if
you were to compare two printed qurans
you going to see differences between
them and when we say the various
different ways to recite the Quran we
are not talking about different voices
or different styles we're talking about
slight differences in pronunciations
slight differences in letters slight
differences inat in North Africa there
is a slightly different text uh that is
uh based on a slightly different reading
and then too in some parts of Africa uh
there is another reading of the Quran
and a matching manuscript that is
prevalent they recite the Quran in a
slightly different way not just a voice
or not just a a a a speaking style but
also changes in letters and and and
words
andat sometimes the different words give
the verses different
meanings sometimes the different words
lead to contradictory meanings
gets even worse because there are
multiple versions of the different
kirat and yet there's only one Quran
right so the 10 different kirat with
different Arabic letters and different
Arabic words and different meanings are
somehow only one Quran aren't
they this means that according to Islam
1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1
equals
1 and each of these readings really is
the Quran isn't it let's consider three
different versions The HS version is the
Quran the wassh version is the Quran the
aldori version is the Quran but the HS
version isn't the wassh version the
wassh version isn't the alori version
the alori version isn't the havs version
and yet there's only one Quran so the
Quran is one in essence seven in aru 10
in kirat and 114 in Surah hence
according to Islam 1 = 7 = 10 equals
114 here our Muslim friends might object
but David we're only raising this
objection because you say that there are
three persons in the Trinity it's
impossible for three persons to be one
in essence or
nature is it now let's see if your
Prophet agrees with you in sah Muslim
1874 Muhammad tells his followers recite
the Quran for it will come on the day of
Resurrection interceding for its
companions recite the two bright ones
Surah Al bakar and Surah al- Imran for
they will come on the day of
Resurrection as if they were two clouds
or as if they were two Shadows or as if
they were two flocks of birds in ranks
pleading on behalf of their companions
notice it will come the Quran will come
interceding for its
companions but individual suras will
also come as flocks of birds pleading on
behalf of Muslims so the Quran as a
whole inter EDS but individual soras
also intercede they speak they intercede
they plead other suras of the Quran will
intercede as well in sun Abu da 1400
Muhammad says that another Surah of the
Quran Surah 67 will intercede on behalf
of its companion until he is
Forgiven since Muhammad tells us that
multiple suras of the Quran act as
personal agents I think it's safe to
conclude that all of the suras of the
Quran act as personal agents unless our
Muslim friends want to convince us that
some suras are personal agents While
others aren't which would suggest that
different suras actually have different
Natures but notice if all of the suras
of the Quran act as personal agents
speaking and interceding and pleading
then there are 114 personal agents
within the Quran and yet the Quran also
acts as a single personal agent Sun IB
Maja
3781 the Quran will come on the day of
Resurrection like a Pale Man and will
say I am the one that kept you awake at
night and made you thirsty during the
day according to Muhammad there
are4 personal agents in the Quran they
speak they intercede they plead
but the Quran appears as a single Pale
Man a single personal agent 114 persons
in a single pale man that's got to be a
record so here again 114 equals 1 in
Islam try to get your mind around this
Allah's speech is eternal that Eternal
speech is also personal it appears as a
man speaking and interceding
but within the one nature of that
Eternal personal speech there are 114
personal agents that speak and intercede
and
plead now let me ask all my Muslim
friends out
there what was your objection to the
mathematics of the
Trinity why do you keep saying that the
Trinity is irrational and
absurd what was your objection to the
claim of Jesus and the apostles and the
prophet
that God is one in one way but more than
one in another
way if you insist as you keep doing that
the doctrine of the Trinity must be
rejected because it leads to
mathematical absurdities well then we
have no choice but to reject your God
your prophet and your book for producing
so many mathematical
absurdities tell me why is it that the
absolute dumbest objections to
Christianity 1+ 1+ 1 equals 1 in Trinity
become the most popular Muslim
objections to
Christianity do you really want to know
my Muslim
friends it's because you serve the
single most obvious false prophet in
history and that sth Century Arabian
Caravan robber you call your Prophet
contradicts the teachings of the most
indisputably reliable and trustworthy
and miraculous person in history Jesus
Christ your Scholars and apologists
don't want you thinking about the
unmistakable differences between Jesus
and Muhammad so they fill your heads
with laughably stupid objections to
Christianity along with lies about your
profit to keep you
distracted your creator the creator of
the universe revealed something about
his eternal nature he revealed it
through Jesus Christ the apostles and
the true
prophets and you mock what he revealed
because you'd rather believe the most
obvious false prophet in history and the
scholars and dagand who constantly lie
to you to keep you in a state of
ignorance if you still don't believe me
when I tell you that your Scholars and
daag gists are trying to keep you in a
state of ignorance just ask
yourself why is it that most of the
information David just shared with me in
this video is information that I will
only hear from David and maybe from some
other Christians or a few atheists but
never from Muslim Scholars and
apologists even though it comes from
Islam's most trusted
sources if your Scholars and apologists
are hiding this from
you what else are they hiding
[Music]